Traductor: Kevin Álvarez
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Ahora sabemos más cosas.
Sabemos, por ejemplo, que
nuestros propios dispositivos
nos escuchan y nos geolocalizan,
aunque les pidamos que no lo hagan.
Sabemos que nuestra cara y nuestra voz
se utilizan para entrenar algoritmos
de reconocimiento biométrico,
que nos identifican incluso
sin nuestro consentimiento
y sin que lo sepamos.
El gobierno chino utiliza
sistemas de reconocimiento facial
para controlar a sus propios ciudadanos
y para entrenarlos con su famoso
sistema de crédito social chino,
pero también los utiliza para encontrar
a los chinos musulmanes, a los uigures,
y meterlos en campos de concentración.
El gobierno de EE.UU. utiliza estos datos
para encontrar a inmigrantes y refugiados,
separarlos de sus hijos y encerrarlos
en sus propios campos de concentración.
En estos cuatro años
también hemos aprendido
que hay agencias de marketing político
que utilizan esos datos
para hacer campañas de desinformación,
que justifican ese tipo de vulneraciones
de los derechos humanos.
Hay gente que piensa
que Internet se ha roto,
que la tecnología está
acabando con la democracia,
que ha sido un experimento fallido
y que hay que volver a empezar.
Yo no pienso eso.
Yo no creo que se haya roto el proyecto
que empezó hace ahora exactamente 50 años,
en el que el profesor Leonard Kleinrock
conectó un ordenador
del tamaño de una lavandería,
que había en la Universidad de California,
en Los Ángeles,
con otro ordenador
del tamaño de un rinoceronte,
que había en el Instituto de Investigación
de Stanford, 800 kilómetros más al sur.
Tampoco creo que se hayan roto
los protocolos que crearon
los padres fundadores de Internet.
El protocolo TCP/IP,
que estaba diseñado precisamente
para que los gobiernos que
estaban pagando las infraestructuras
a través de las operadoras,
que eran públicas
como Teléfonica en aquel momento,
pudieran espiar a sus propios ciudadanos.
Y creo que la aplicación
más popular de la web,
es decir la World Wide Web,
que creó Tim Berners-Lee
y que abrió con una licencia libre
para que fuera de todos y para todos,
tampoco creo que este rota.
Pienso que no se equivocaba
John Perry Barlow
cuando en su declaración de independencia
del ciberespacio
le dijo a los gobiernos en Davos:
"Sacad vuestras sucias manos de la red,
porque es nuestra".
El problema no es la red,
pero es algo que le pasa a la red.
Yo lo veo como una especie
de hongo oportunista,
que pilló la red en un momento
que estaba muy baja de defensas.
Y un poco como los casinos y la heroína,
ha ido haciéndose fuerte
a lo lago de los últimos años
gracias a la precariedad
y a las políticas de austeridad.
Y está súper bien catalogado,
tiene varios nombres.
Lo habréis conocido como
capitalismo de plataformas,
capitalismo de la vigilancia,
feudalismo digital...
Es muy fácil de identificar porque
siempre opera de la misma manera:
ofrece una infraestructura
para que hagas lo que quieras,
pero esa infraestructura son
sus servidores, datacenters, algoritmos
y todos los datos que generas,
los que generas tú,
los que generan tus clientes,
los que generan las personas
que trabajan con tu servicio,
alimentan sus algoritmos predictivos
de inteligencia artificial
para que ellos te vigilen,
te controlen y te manipulen.
Esta lógica en los últimos años
se ha ido colando en nuestras casas,
se ha ido colando en nuestras ciudades,
se está colando en nuestra industria,
se está colando en nuestras cosechas,
y se está colando en nuestras escuelas.
Y hoy vengo a deciros que
da igual que tiréis el móvil
y os vayáis a meditar al monte.
No importa, no sirve de nada.
No solo porque hay satélites
que están equipados con software
de reconocimiento facial
y os van a reconocer igual.
Lamentablemente, ya no basta
con que utilicéis criptografía.
Esto fue lo que dije hace cuatro años:
"usad criptografía".
Por favor, seguid usando criptografía,
utilizad servicios que
no exploten vuestros datos.
Pero ya no basta con eso,
porque ya no es un problema individual.
No es como el colesterol,
que te comes un aguacate y se te pasa,
esto es un problema colectivo.
Un problema colectivo
como el cambio climático,
y eso significa que si reciclas,
si eres vegetariano,
si no coges el coche, no coges aviones...
Está muy bien.
Está muy bien todo eso,
pero no te salvas del cambio climático
solo haciendo eso.
Necesitas acción colectiva.
Y no tiene que ser nada
particularmente heroico,
ni particularmente grande.
Por ejemplo, los vecinos
de mi exbarrio en Berlín, de Kreuzberg,
han estado dos años tratando de detener
la instalación de un Google Campus
en el barrio, delante del canal.
Y lo han conseguido.
Pero lo importante casi no es eso,
lo importante en es que en esos dos años,
mientras estaban organizando
han creado una plataforma
que ahora mismo está ayudando
a todos los negocios del barrio
a salirse de las plataformas digitales
y utilizar servicios que funcionan en red,
que funcionan en comunidad,
y que benefician no solo a las tiendas
sino también a los vecinos del barrio.
En Cataluña hay una plataforma para evitar
que los padres firmen permisos
para que se usen los productos de Google
en las escuelas públicas,
son productos que espían a sus hijos.
De lo local a lo general,
de lo pequeño a lo grande
no sabemos adónde puede ir,
pero esta plataforma se puede convertir
en algo mucho más interesante.
Los ciudadanos de Hong Kong
están peleando por conservar su democracia
y en el proceso han aprendido varias cosas
Están casi reinventando la protesta.
Han aprendido a cegar los sistemas
de reconocimiento facial con láser,
y han aprendido a utilizar sus teléfonos
para hacer redes instantáneas,
comunitarias e hiperlocales,
sin utilizar las antenas
que controla el gobierno chino
y las bases de datos
que controla el gobierno chino.
Ese tipo de redes, redes comunitarias,
redes hiperlocales, redes ciudadanas,
llevan años expandiéndose
por Latinoamérica,
que es un lugar donde
el 60 % de la población
no tiene acceso a Internet.
Y también hay actividades
como guifi.net en España,
o New York Mesh, en Estados Unidos...
Podéis aprender a crear
vuestra propia red común,
comunitaria, hiperlocal
en vuestro edificio, en vuestra calle,
en vuestro barrio, en vuestro pueblo.
De lo pequeño, a lo grande.
Para luego conectaros con todas las demás,
experimentar con eso.
Pero lo que he venido a pediros hoy
es lo siguiente,
ya que nos convocan una vez más
a la gran fiesta de la democracia
y que vamos a tener que sufrir
una nueva campaña política,
que nos va a torturar
durante un mes entero
quiero que le pidáis a los candidatos
que os expliquen qué van a hacer
para solucionar el problema
del capitalismo de la vigilancia.
Qué van a hacer para
proteger vuestros datos,
qué van a hacer para proteger
vuestros datos individuales y colectivos.
Y también, que le digáis
al presidente del Gobierno
que la próxima vez que se reúna
con los jefes de Facebook, Apple,
Microsoft y Amazon
no sea para darles las llaves del reino.
Que no queremos que nos administre Amazon,
no queremos que nos administre una empresa
que se dedica a la extracción de datos
para hacer algoritmos que nos vigilan,
que nos encuentran
donde no queremos ser encontrados
y que nos controlan.
Que ponga la tecnología
al servicios de los ciudadanos,
en lugar de los ciudadanos
al servicio del poder.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)